a california family still can't
understand why a complete stranger would
allegedly kill a young woman he just met
she just was so kind and it just
it
it just infuriates me that
he really showed her no remorse she had
no idea who she was
what she meant to so many people
she is talking about her 24 year old
cousin destiny jackson her body was
found on the 11th shot to death and
dumped in the desert near sloan the
family held a vigil praying that police
would find her killer while the
following day her stolen car was spotted
in southern california and after a brief
chase 21-year-old albert ontario was
captured and confessed
how do you even answer for that
how do you deem what's enough justice
for what he did to her
he
stole her life because he wanted to
steal her car
according to the police report ontario
and jackson met online and then in
person at cactus and amigo streets
apparently he admitted to investigators
that he told her he was sorry and shot
her three times before dumping her body
and then heading home to the l.a area
during his arrest police discovered two
guns and multiple blood splatters inside
the victim's car ontario faces a charge
of open murder and robbery with use of a
deadly weapon